where is this fellow
as well like a little child is I'm
always speaking my words okay
come on is bad look after disrespecting
Kalani I swallow he has something coming
for him
hey man I need a fan spam it's melissia
here this week's episode of happily ever
after was the opposite of a fairy tale
for most of the couple's I'll update you
on their storylines in just a few but
first let's talk about the couple who
had it the worst I swellow and Kalani
following their big argument last week
Kalani's dad got face to face without
swellow
after he refused to come out of his room
during their son's birthday party I was
really strange to not see a soul around
I really thought that he was gonna be
out you know with the boys all right I'm
gonna go check on him and see it's his
birthday party and everybody's outside
waiting telling you you should come
outside again I'm just frustrated I
don't
yeah just wait for it Kalani's dad aka
mr. Lowe yeah he's about to set things
straight
I don't know you fell right now he'll
play the part of the sides birthday you
know yeah he needs me out to spend time
with Sammy yeah but hey you know I mean
I promised my daughter in my life then I
was gonna make his heat by the next time
there won't be no more talking of his
estate as well don't you just love
Kalani's dad it's just something about
him right he does not take any mess I
swellow listened and made his way
outside after their talk but it was a
bit awkward it got even more awkward
after he put his arm around Kalani
because at this point I swellow said in
the house for so long that everybody at
the party knows about their big fight
and he's just standing there
as if it never happened he also didn't
apologize to Kalani for disrespecting
her and she mentioned that in this
episode she talks about how it's normal
for them to brush major issues under the
rug in their relationship in act as if
it never happened but obviously they've
done that a wee bit too much now because
things are starting to boil over based
off of next week's preview
Kalani's dad is one conversation away
from letting a swellow have it i'm
trying my best not to get a violet
[Music]
boiling over next up we have CIN Jin who
just doesn't want to be contained he
revealed in this episode that he is not
trying to have a life in America with
Tanya
I love Tanya but I don't want to stay
long to me in this face because I think
there is better opportunities out there
you know I also kind of been homesick
since I left if our plans don't align
and we can't find a compromise will be
Bofur happy and that'll be the end of us
well each each at it with Tanya in
sinchon about a month ago and time you
spoke about whether or not creating the
life abroad what Sinjin is an option for
her i always bent down to kind of live
in south africa when we first met before
traveling to Thailand I was ready to
like move out South Africa permanently
well like temporarily permanently like a
year or two I think currently our best
bet is to be here in the States making
you know the US dollar and just really
being able to save up and then I'm kind
of down to see where the future takes us
I definitely want roots here in the
States but doesn't mean it needs to be
full-time we'll see how that goes our
final highlight goes to Andre who got
called out by his Moldovan friends for
being a housewife in America my dad
about goes for that juice pagoda
and Americans do something something is
wrong in here
America is the kind of changing Andre
he's a hard worker is becoming too soft
I don't like you
I like Andres friends they're honest and
they didn't hold back at all and you
have Elizabeth just sitting there taking
it all in
and enjoying every bit of it next week
on happily ever after Larissa starts to
see her ex-boyfriend Eric again feel
like you had a little bit sheepy looks
feel like this time I'd let the money
flow what should I be buying with my
money my boobs and after getting off to
a pretty rough start Jess and Miss
Debbie spent some quality time together
in Brazil so what do you think of Jess
minutes with her why don't you go and
I'm with her for a bit go outside take a
walk
I don't know Jess understands the bond
that Colt and I have if she tries to
break it she's gonna be in for a rude
awakening
come on Miss Debbie just give her a
break even if it's just for a little bit
let's give her a little break okay enjoy
Brazil enjoy yourself
all right 90 day fan spam we want to
make sure you stay updated on all the
latest news from the 90 day universe so
make sure you stick with ET because here
we're covering it all all right see you
next time
[Music]